the prince versus the paper an
unprecedented legal battle has begun in
which Prince Harry is taking on his
lifelong tormentors the Tabloid press
his lawyers have selected a series of
articles by the mirror group where they
claim information about the prince was
illegally obtained the first of them
when he was just a boy one where his
mother visited him at school and another
where his Nanny took him to hospital
aged 11. the court was told as evidence
the mirror paid private investigators
for information that was good evidence
because you've got the the story about
him being rushed to rushed to hospital
in the paper you've got the payments to
a notorious private investigator then
you've got Prince Harry's own account of
this and Prince Harry thinking well
who's leaking this is it is it is it is
it people in my closer is it my nanny
the next bombshell from Prince Harry's
lawyer David Sherborne seen here on the
left were letters from Princess Diana to
TV presenter Michael Barrymore in one
she apologizes for a story getting out
writing nobody knew about our
conversations phone call how deeply
sorry I am what I considered to be a
private matter has become public
property what David Sherborne is saying
well there's any other one possible way
this could have happened I.E Princess
Diana's phone is hacked now Sylvan says
in the letters doesn't she no one are in
my circle told anybody exactly are you
there's no other possible way of knowing
it and if there's ever a red flag to
Prince Harry it's his mum being hacked
the mirror group say it's pure
speculation that Diana was hacked and
have admitted only one breach of the
rules against Prince Harry their lawyers
said many of the stories involved
information already in the public domain
some put out by the Royal household or
even the Duke himself and they said
there's no evidence that Prince Harry's
phone was ever hacked Prince Harry's
lawyer says that his client was the
victim of unlawful information gathering
from when he was a young boy at school
through the death of his mother into
army training and young adulthood there
was no time or area of his life when he
was safe from this kind of activity that
nothing was sacrosanct nothing was out
of bounds
the court was told this infected his
relationships the intrusion too much for
his then girlfriend Chelsea Davey and
they say a story published in 2003 about
an alleged disagreement between William
and Harry began to erode trust between
the brothers
there was surprise expressed by the
judge that the Duke of Sussex wasn't in
court on standby to give evidence in the
afternoon but that moment comes tomorrow
where he will walk through these doors
and face down the newspaper's lawyers
it's his day in court but their chance
to pull his claim apart Jason Farrell
Sky News